what's going on guys today we're talking
Spielberg
he's got bridge of spies hitting
theaters this weekend so we are going to
break down the greatest Steven Spielberg
blockbusters of all time and tell you
what's number one
so this bracket includes his big popcorn
movies the blockbusters not as more
dramatic fare so basically we don't have
to talk about history's most horrible
events in comparison to dinosaurs and
we've got an awesome panel to decide it
for us first he's the entertainment
reporter for io9 jermaine Lussier he's
ah he's a good pal the show you know
from schmoes know the podcast and
YouTube channel and Fandango Kristian
harloff and the reigning movie fights
world champion and all-around swell guy
Dan Merle just tell you how we figured
out our seating the movies are ranked
according to their IMDB ranking and a
movie has to receive two out of three
votes in order to move on fellas you're
ready to rock run this first matchup
right off the bat guys Indiana Jones
Raiders of the Lost Ark the number one
versus Indiana Jones kingdom of the
Crystal Skull Raiders are lost our
Raiders Raider oh yeah of course
Crystal Skull is gone 60 a 16 seed never
beats a 100 number eight Minority Report
versus number nine Temple of Doom oh boy
oh boy I feel like for me uh Temple of
Doom sort of came out a formative time
of my life and I watch it way more than
I watched my no report so no I think I'm
leaning temple it's me okay I'm not it's
I know there are temple people I'm not a
temple person and I think that my own
report was actually pretty visionary
movie I'm gonna go Minority Report whoa
we are all tied up 1-1 Kristian harloff
break this tie look my night report when
I first started I don't good movies I've
watched it again and again and again
dance right it is kind of revolutionary
as far as what they're doing now with
technology where they're gonna go I love
Temple to do man I'm one of those people
I know that some people hate it I love
it I love the fact that it's a it's a
prequel is it cheesy absolutely monkey
brains temple do for the
temper and do everything yes here is our
number four seed jaws against our number
13 seed hook I do enjoy a hook very much
I know I don't care about the 30 percent
on Rotten Tomatoes daily a dance
sweating over here ah its jaws man jaws
is one of the best movies of all time
not just spill or movies yeah it's a no
brainer it's its jaws danlove hook I
loved bangerang
I loved Rufio I love fake imaginary food
but it's Jaws jaws here is the Battle of
initials number five ET versus number 12
ai come on I think these early rounds
are pretty obvious I mean you have to go
with ET and AI is a movie is very
special I really really like it oh yeah
Jude Law's robotic male prostitute yeah
well you know this parts I like parts
you like sure but uh Dan yeah lots to
admire and AI but the as a whole it
never really came together for me ET
yeah I uh I love UT but I think it was
also the reason I admire the movie is
because it was almost it was like a nice
homage from Spielberg to Kubrick that's
why the me III admire it but ET i watch
over and over when my fear moves my
childhood and it's still the emotions
still play to this the yeah ET no
question the number two movie Indiana
Jones and the Last Crusade versus the
number fifteen War of the Worlds Dan a
lot of people out there don't like War
of the Worlds and I don't get that I
like that movie a lot I think Tom Cruise
is great in it I think that the the
aliens are very menacingly portrayed I
think there's a real dread and a terror
when they show up
having said that Last Crusade might be
the best in the end of Jones movie in my
book I'm gonna go with last week's
crusade harloff I am one of those people
who don't love War of the Worlds III
thought the first like 15-20 minutes I'd
movie like terrifying the sound and I
just thought it just lost its way so
it's a no brainer for me I agree that I
would Raiders and lust Crusader always
like back and forth for me so it's less
person here we go
the number seven film Close Encounters
of the Third Kind and the number 10 film
The Adventures of Tintin
it is really underrated by the way it's
the best adventure film he's done in a
long time but again those early
Spielberg movies just will never get old
watch the internet explode I'm going
Tintin oh I know look I love Close
Encounters
but I agree with Jermaine the fact that
how underrated Tintin was will it be
Tintin for the win-win Dan respect to
Tenten but I gotta go Close Encounters
ooh man
here's another doozy number three
Jurassic Park versus number 14 the lost
world with Dan go first
yeah I think it's been proven that any
dinosaur ESIC Park movie with the word
world and the title is probably not
gonna be awesome
so a Jurassic Park of lost world is a
fifth of the original movie BAM
Jermaine yeah dress Jurassic Park okay
all right and finally number six catch
me if you can vs. number eleven the
terminal they call this the hottest
matchup of it I almost fell asleep in
the terminal I hate to say yeah I love
catch me if you can when we're going to
see that movie going I don't know if I
care about this story and I was blown
away by the movie another underrated
Spielberg film yeah it's phenomenal it
wins hands down catch me if you can
I feel like has been lost in the shuffle
nobody talks about catch me if you can
and it's got a great performance from
Leonardo DiCaprio a great non Winkie
performance from Christopher Walken and
Tom Hanks is great in a to Amy Adams in
a very early early role Garner Jennifer
Garner yeah uh yeah I love catch me if
you can oh yeah yeah make it a unanimous
great all right MA st. Paige lot here
Josh but this is where it's gonna get
how we got rid of the fat we are down to
the final eight gentlemen who this first
one let's do it
Raiders vs. Temple of Doom Christian
readers lost or Raiders germane yeah I
love Temple of Doom but against Raiders
is just a comparison gotcha
Dan for the record if tipple dibs I
could clear Minority Report for me I'm
so
yeah I'm going readers okay this is a
matchup that will keep people up dark
and lonely nights jaws verse et alright
Jermaine let's start with you man
man it's it's this this is a tough one
you talk to Sophie's Choice it's the
best two of the best I think I'm just
gonna go with my heart instead of my gut
I think the gut is that jaws is the
better movie but for me
et just has it's like the definition of
the Spielberg magic I think et is where
you you it all comes together in a
different way so I'm going to pick et
over Jules boom that's one for the
flying bike over the bigger boat
Christian I'd like to hear his alright
Dan when somebody for the last 20 years
when somebody's asked what my favorite
movie is I always say jaws I mean just
Robert Shaw and the cast and just what
he did with that movie I can quote it
front to back on the other hand et is
the movie that made me want to make
movies et was the movie first Steven
Stewart movie I ever saw and there's a
moment in et with John Williams score
which i think is the best score ever
written for a movie ever when they're
riding the bikes and they take off and
they fly across the Sun every time I see
it and I've seen it 50 times I get
goosebumps so I think I gotta go with et
whoa Wow Dan are you mad at yourself for
that choice I know cuz they're two great
movies dan are you crying no I'm not
crying I feel like people are gonna
understand it cuz jaws is my favorite
movie of all time but ET how that made
me love movies alright put you in that
position
Kristen for the record what would you
have said strangely we probably would've
been a unanimous all right let's keep
the second round going Indiana Jones and
the Last Crusade versus Close Encounters
of the Third Kind Jermaine this is much
easier for me
Last Crusade just such a rousing
adventure movie so much good things
happening in there so awesome I picked
Last Crusade one for the Last Crusade
Christian Tintin Oh actually uh not in
there Last Crusade Last Crusade moving
on
any thoughts Dan I might have given the
edge to Close Encounters - really yeah
yeah yeah watch that movie again
Jurassic Park against catch me if you
can
leo versus the dinos Dan it's Jurassic
Park it was my it was my Star Wars as
far as theatrical as far as like sitting
in a movie and go like wow seeing this
or something I never seen before in my
life
yep I gotta go dress I love catch me if
you can this is really hard because I
think catch me if you can is the better
movie but if we're talking about
spielberg blockbusters Jurassic Park
gotcha
the Final Four is set Wow oh boy oh boy
Raiders of the Lost Ark vs. ET Kristian
harloff I love ET you have not shut up
about it
bTW I remember seeing as a kid I'm
seeing it with my mom just there's so
much to it it's no Raiders of the Lost
Ark man thank you sir Dan talk to us
when you think of Steven Spielberg two
of the things that you think of maybe
the first two things you think of are
the bike across the moon and Indiana
Jones rolling from the boulder it's like
every criteria that you could possibly
make this decision on both movies meet
it so I got to go again with my heart
and for the movie that made me fall in
love with movies and and I love Raiders
I got to go ET Wow you are all in on
Ebola nany T there we go and Jermaine
you are going to break this 1-1 tie
Christian made some great points where
et is just an amazingly special movie
but if you look at like just what is the
quintessential adventure movie serratus
Lost Ark who is one of the best
characters ever made Indiana Jones you
know et et is a character is great all
the characters that but freaking Indiana
Jones there you have it Raiders of the
Lost Ark going to the fine eats he went
home it's like it's like I broke up with
a really cool girlfriend to go out with
another girlfriend and now she wasn't
that cool at all and I'm just left alone
whoo buddy Indiana Jones and the Last
Crusade versus Jurassic Park for me as
much as I love Last Crusade for me this
is a pretty easy straightforward
Jurassic Park I actually disagree I
think that you have to see Harrison Ford
and Sean Connery the two of them
together when do you get that you don't
get that dress
world this is one of some of the moments
in there and just you have chose poorly
we all say that it shows wisely we use
it I loved the Last Crusade let's
receive harloff you're breaking the
internet today I wonder I'm curious I
don't know if people are gonna disagree
as much with that one may I could be
wrong I think I think it's gonna be even
split yeah we're all locked up at one
one Dan I'd like I'd like to point out
that Christian just accidentally said
Jurassic world when he met drastic park
and it breaks my heart
oh right nightmare I mean we have one
Indiana Jones movie in the finals
already some people say it's appropriate
to settle this duel once and for all to
pit the two best Indiana Jones movies
against each other and I love Last
Crusade
but Jurassic Park man uh et was the
movie that made me fall in love with
movies Jurassic Park is the movie that
made me become obsessed with Steven
Spielberg which I am to this day and it
was the movie that showed me that
literally anything is now possible
anything I could dream of can be a movie
now I gotta go Jurassic Park Jurassic
Park moving on final round here it is
the park versus the Ark Jurassic Park
versus Raiders of the Lost Ark two of my
favorite movies probably too much of
favorite Spielberg movies - movies are
very formative that I rewatched time and
time again Alan Grant wouldn't exist
without Indiana Jones and so I think my
the best Spielberg movie is Raiders of
the Lost Ark that's 104 the Ark of the
Covenant in Raiders of the Lost Ark Dan
Raiders of the Lost Ark is great there's
a lot of great imagery in that movie
then and that character will live on
forever I think people see Harrison Ford
more as Indiana Jones and they see him
as Harrison Ford even maybe Han Solo but
again I've got to just go with my heart
and my personal experience and I have to
go to Rasik Park because that movie
literally changed my life the park is
still open
it's one-one Jurassic Park versus
Raiders Kristian harloff it all comes
down to you Dan is certainly not alone
with many people out there what that
movie meant to so many people and what
it meant for film if without traffic
park you don't get the
these movies that we have today rage is
a lost art um
it is a movie to me that as we're Dan
said to be he became a movie fan that's
the movie that did it for me and Raiders
started at all it's just one of those
movies it's exactly what you wanted
old serials I love it it's Raiders lost
are there you have it Raiders of the
Lost Ark is our number one it wins the
Steven Spielberg blockbuster bracket
gentlemen final thoughts on this
Jurassic world I mean partly dan how
does it out how do you feel having gone
through this emotional rollercoaster
single one of my favorites was
eliminated so I betrayed my favorite
movie and I have nothing to show for it
you know I don't think you betray
anything I mean like he's just made so
many great movies that and you were
forced to make a choice
a crazy battle a crazy fight but Raiders
is our number one what is your number 1
Spielberg movie of all time let us know
in the comments section below best
answer we are going to send you a screen
junkies t-shirt let's never forget that
Christian picked in 10 I want to thank
my panel Germaine Lussier check them out
on io9 Kristian harloff subscribe to the
schmoes know youtube channel and check
them out on Fandango Dan Merle just be
here yeah he'll be around I want to
thank you for watching on how Rudnik hit
me up on Twitter bye bye let's just face
it Matt Damon and be dead multiple
multiple times ok no wow
this is the die hard of space bill take
a stab he gets frozen he gets exploded
where was Hans Gruber exactly